we know that three points define a
triangle so if i were to take three
random points here so let's call that
point a
point b
and then let's say this is point c right
over here if we say that these three
points are the vertices of a triangle
they define a unique triangle so this
would be triangle a
try to draw my lines as straight as
possible triangle a
b
c
now we've also learned in the last few
videos that triangle abc has a unique
circumcenter and that is a point that is
equidistant to these three vertices it's
equidistant to these three points so and
the way we can find it is we draw a
perpendicular bisector of each of these
sides and where the three perpendicular
bisectors intersect and we show that
they always intersect in a unique point
that is that circumcenter and i'll do it
really quick right over here so let's
say this is the perpendicular bisector
of that side this is the perpendicular
bisector of that side and this is the
perpendicular bisector i want to go from
this is the perpendicular bisector of
that side so these are all perpendicular
this is perpendicular and they each
bisect the sides so this side b to this
point is going to be equal to this point
2 a
a to this point is going to be equal to
that point to c
c that this point
is going to be equal to that point to b
and this point right over here we've
already talked about we'll call that
point o we call that the circumcenter o
is circumcenter
circumcenter this is all a little bit of
review so if you have three points you
have a unique triangle that unique
triangle has a unique circumcenter which
is equidistant to the three points of
the triangle three i should say the
three vertices of the triangle and that
distance that distance between the
circumcenter and the three points the
three vertices i should say
so let me draw that in a different color
so this distance o a the length of o a
the length of the length of oc and the
length of ob
so oa is equal to oc is equal to ob
which is the circum radius
circum radius
and it we've learned when we first
talked about circles if you give me a
point and if we find the locus of all
points that are equidistant from that
point then that is a circle i'm going to
say locus allows means the set of all
points if you give me any point if you
give me any point right over here so
that's an arbitrary point and you also
specify a radius and you say what is the
set of all the points on this
two-dimensional plane that are
equidistant that are that radius away
from the center it uniquely defines a
circle that's how we defined a circle
right over here
and similarly if you say look if you
start with the center at o and you say
all of the points that are the circum
radius away from o it will uniquely
identify a circle and that circle will
contain the points a b and c because
those are those are the circum radius
away from o so they are included in that
set
so the circle would look something like
let me draw it
it would look something like this
try my best to
best to draw it just like that now
everything we talked about just now in
the last few minutes is all review we
know all of this but i went over it just
to kind of reinstate a pretty
interesting idea that if you give me
three points
if you give me three points
that defines a unique triangle
unique triangle and if you have a unique
triangle and let me let me make it clear
this is three
non-collinear points so three points not
on the same line
the same line
if you have three points that are not on
the same line that defines a unique
triangle for any unique triangle you
have a unique circum center
unique
circumcenter
circum center
and
circumradius i'll write i'll rewrite it
i don't want to get lazy confuse you
circum
radius
and if you give me any point in space
any unique point and a radius the set of
all points that are exactly that radius
away from it that defines a unique
circle
that defines a unique
a unique circle so we went through all
of this business of talking about the
unique triangle and unique circumcenter
and the unique radius to really just
show you that if you give me any three
points
if you give me any three points that
eventually really just defines a unique
circle so just as you need
three points to define a triangle you
also need three points to define a
circle two points won't do it and one
way to think about it is if you give me
two points if you give me two points
there's there's an infinite number of
triangles that i construct with those
two points because i can put the third
point anywhere i could construct this
triangle i could construct this triangle
i could construct
this triangle i can construct this
triangle and all of these triangles are
going to have different circumcenters
and different radiuses and so they're
going to have different circles that
circum that circumscribe about those
triangles so this one so for example
this would be one circle that could go
around that could circumscribe that
triangle you could have this circle
right over here so you see clearly very
clearly that two points are not enough
you need three points three points lead
to a triangle you lead to a unique
circle so that by itself is kind of cool
now another question is is if i have
just a circle and if it's circumscribe
if it's circumstance if it's
circumscribed about an arbitrary
triangle is the center of that is the
center of that circle necessarily the
circumcenter so let's think about that a
little bit because there are some there
are some i guess unnatural or i wouldn't
say unnatural non-intuitive cases here
so if i draw a circle
if i draw a circle right over here its
center is right over there and if i draw
an arbitrary triangle where all of the
vertices of that triangle are on or on
this circle is this center necessarily
the circumcenter of that triangle so let
me draw let me draw a crazy situation so
let me draw one where this this thing is
clearly outside of the triangle so we
could have a triangle that looks like
this and it's clearly all three vertices
sit on the circle so you might at first
say wait there's no way this could be
the circumcenter it's not even inside
the triangle but remember this point
this point right here is equidistant to
every point on the circle i should say
every point on this circle is
equidistant from this point they are all
the radius away and all three points of
this triangle are on the circle so they
are all exactly a radius away from this
point right over here so this distance
right over here is going to be a radius
this distance right over here is going
to be a radius and this distance right
over here is going to be a radius
now this point is clearly equidistant
from that point and that point we know
that it's exactly r away from both of
those both of those vertices of the
triangle so if it's equidistant and we
prove this in a previous video if it's
equidistant from both of those points it
must be on the perpendicular bisector of
the segment that joins those two points
so this must be on the perpendicular
bisector
so that's it's perpendicular and it
bisects that segment right over there
but we can make the same argument for
this segment right over here because
this point is r from this the center
we're calling oh i'm i'm tired of just
saying this point
point o is equidistant from let me label
these so let's call this a
b
c so we already said point o is
equidistant from c and b so it must be
on the perpendicular bisector of bc and
it's also equidistant from a and b it's
r away from both because a and b both
sit on the circle they're both a radius
away from the center so it also must sit
on the perpendicular bisector of a b
so it also must sit on the perpendicular
that doesn't look
as
that didn't let me draw it a little bit
neater there you go so it must also be
on this perpendicular bisector and then
finally it also is equidistant from a
it's for the same distance from a as it
is from c
because those are both r away they both
sit on the circle so it must be on the
perpendicular bisector of ac as well of
ac as well so ac is right over here and
this is what the interesting thing is
we're seeing that the interest that
these the three the three perpendicular
bisectors of the three sides of this
triangle they do definitely intersect
but they are intersecting at a point
outside of that circle outside of that
triangle and that point is the center of
this circle so once again the last point
right that the last idea is o is
equidistant from a and c so it must sit
on the perpendicular bisector of ac
which would look something like this
which would look something like
something like that
so once again we see the three
perpendicular bisectors are intersecting
at a unique point and o really is the
circumcenter
so if you take any circle if you take a
circle and if you put any triangle whose
vertices sit on the circle the center of
that circle is its circumcenter so we
just drew a situation where this is a
circumcenter that sits outside of the
triangle proper so point o is also going
to be the circumcenter of
of this triangle
of this triangle right over here and
point o is also going to be the
circumcenter of
this triangle right over here
it's going to sit on all three
perpendicular bisectors of this and we
know that because it's equidistant from
all three points of or of any of these
triangles that where the vertices sit on
the circle itself